في السادس من يناير يتذكر الامريكيون
موقعه الكابيتول هجوم يحيي البيت الابيض
ذكرى ويمنح الرئيس الامريكي
اوسمه ل 12 من مسؤول انتخابات عام 2020
وضباط انفاذ القانون
[تصفيق]
عمن مر على الهجوم ومع ذكر الثانيه له
تعود الاحداث للاذهان انصر الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب يقتحمون
رفضا لنتائج الانتخابات الرئاسيه
الامريكيه عام 2020 وسعيا لتعطيل نتائجها
السادس من يناير عام 2021 اربعه قتلى من
المدنيين ووفاه شوطين اثناء محاولته سد
الهجوم
اعقده فرض حضره تجوال ثم القاء القبض على
ما يزيد على 500 من المشتبه بهم في اثاره
الشغب ولكن ماذا عن الرئيس الامريكي
السابق
لجنه الكونجرس المعنيه بالتحقيق في الهجوم
10 جلسات استماع عامه استجوابه خلالها
اكثر من 1000 شاهد بينهم مسؤولون من اداره
ترامب واعضاء من عائلته وضباط الشرطه
الكابتون الى جانب مثير للشغب واصدره
اللجنه المكونه من سبعه ديمقراطيين
وجمهوريين تقريرها النهائي الذي يقع في
840 صفحه متهمه ترامب بالضلع في مؤامره
متعدده الاطراف للانقلاب على نتائج
الانتخابات الرئاسيه حينها الى جانب تحمله
المسؤوليه المباشره في احداث الكابيتون
داهيه وزاره العدل الى اجراء تحقيق معه
لجنه التحقيق واصفا اجراءاتها بالمطارده
السياسيه من قبل خصومه في ظل مواجهته 30
فيدراليه وحمله من البيت الابيض تتهمه مع
انصاره بدعم ما سمته عصيانا على
الديمقراطيه
علي السمان العربيه